[Music]
Jeff Bezos and Lauren Sanchez looking
solid as a rock as in that rock on that
finger this could be it the two all
smiles on Jeff's 500 million dollar
yacht in the south of France where
they've been bopping around at the
canned Film Festival as they also
celebrate getting engaged E.T confirmed
the Amazon founder and former TV anchor
are headed down the aisle after four
years of dating while out and about
Lauren flashed this stunning
heart-shaped ring subtly confirming the
happy news beautiful so where did Jeff
and Lauren's Love Story begin in 2019
the two went public with their Romance
the same day Jeff and his wife of 25
years Mackenzie Scott announced they
were getting divorced we have been
tracking billionaire divorces and so far
the biggest one that we've tracked is
the divorce of Jeff Bezos and his
ex-wife Mackenzie Bezos Scott when she
got about 35 billion dollars worth of
Amazon stock when they divorce at the
same time Lauren was going through a
divorce of her own from Patrick white
cell he's the executive chairman of
endeavor a major Hollywood agency they
share two children together Lauren also
has a son from a previous relationship
with former NFL star Tony Gonzalez both
Jeff and Lauren's divorces were
finalized in 2019. talk to me about this
team that you two have built together
that's a good word we're a really great
teammates and we also have a lot of fun
together and we and we love each other
over the years Jeff and Lauren have
attended public events vacationed and
even gone into business together Laura
and I are very committed to Nature we're
committed to conservation we're
committed to Restoration Lauren serves
as a co-chair for the besos Earth fund
you can't protect what you don't know
and I think people don't know about this
the former Good Day LA host gave some
rare insight into their relationship
with the Wall Street Journal in January
she told the paper Jeff is really funny
and makes her laugh all the time time
quote we love to be together and we love
to work together we fly together we work
out together we're together all the time
I love how we work together we always
look at each other and like we're the
team and get this turns out the fourth
richest man in the world is pretty down
to earth Lauren says every Sunday he
makes the best pancakes in the world
it's easy you know we bring each other
energy we respect each other uh so it's
it it's fun to work together and no
doubt there will be more fun times
coming the couple's way congrats Jeff
and Lauren
foreign
[Music]